El objetivo de este video es demostrar
que las tres medianas de un triángulo
siempre se intersecan en un punto, lo cual
es bastante interesante porque esperarías
que dos rectas diferentes con diferentes
pendientes se intersequen en un punto,
pero tres rectas que se intersecan en un punto es
bastante genial, y esto se cumple para todos los
triángulos. Para hacer esta demostración dibujé un
triángulo arbitrario aquí, puse un vértice en el
origen para simplificar los cálculos y luego otro
vértice en el eje X, y les he dado coordenadas:
este de aquí está en 0,0, este otro de aquí, sólo
estamos diciendo que la coordenada X es a y que
es coma 0 (a,0); este de aquí arriba tiene alguna
coordenada X y alguna coordenada Y que sólo vamos
a llamar b y c. Este es un triángulo arbitrario,
y si tuviera algún otro triángulo que tuviera las
mismas dimensiones que este, y las dimensiones
de este pueden ser cualesquiera porque no hemos
definido a, b y c, podrías mapear este triángulo
a cualquier otro triángulo usando transformaciones
rígidas. Entonces, si podemos demostrar que las
medianas de este triángulo general siempre se
cruzan en un punto, esto será cierto para todos
los triángulos. Así que ahora vamos a dibujar
las medianas. Vamos a dibujar rectas desde cada
vértice hasta el punto medio del lado opuesto,
entonces hemos dibujado todas las medianas y,
en efecto, parece que se intersecan en un punto;
pero para demostrarlo pensemos en cuáles son las
coordenadas de los puntos medios de cada uno de
estos lados. Entonces, ¿cuál es la coordenada
aquí? Pausa el video y piensa en esto. Bueno,
este será el punto medio entre este punto
superior y este punto inferior derecho,
esta longitud es igual a esa longitud, y puedes
calcular el punto medio como el promedio de cada
una de las coordenadas. Así que la coordenada X de
aquí será el promedio de b y a, podemos escribir
esto como a + b / 2; y luego la coordenada Y
será el promedio de c y 0, esto sería c + 0 / 2,
o simplemente c / 2. Y podríamos hacer eso para
cada uno de estos puntos, en este punto aquí su
coordenada X será el promedio de 0 y a, esto es
sólo a / 2, y su coordenada Y será el promedio
de 0 y 0. Puedes ver que se encuentra sobre el eje
X por lo que su coordenada Y es 0. Y por último,
pero no menos importante, ¿cuál es la
coordenada de este punto? Pausa el video
e intenta resolverlo. Muy bien, la coordenada
X será el promedio de b y 0, que es b / 2,
y luego la coordenada Y será el promedio de c y 0,
que es c / 2. La forma en que voy a demostrar que
las tres medianas se intersecan en un punto único
es mostrándote una coordenada que se encuentra en
las tres rectas, si se encuentra en las tres
rectas ese debe ser el punto de intersección,
y este punto de interés está a ⅔ del camino hacia
cualquiera de las medianas. Entonces, una forma
de pensarlo es que la distancia entre el vértice
y este punto es ⅔ de la longitud de la mediana,
así que si sólo observamos esta mediana azul, la
coordenada de este punto que está dos veces más
lejos del vértice que del lado opuesto, será
un promedio ponderado de las coordenadas X y
Y. Cuando encontramos el punto medio y las
cosas tenían la misma distancia, tú también
calculaste las coordenadas, entonces sólo tomaste
su promedio, pero si está más cerca de este lado
tomarás el promedio ponderado que corresponda,
por lo que serán ⅔ (a + b / 2) + ⅓ (0), y luego la
coordenada Y será ⅔ (c / 2) + ⅓ por la coordenada
Y aquí, que es igual a 0. Ahora, una vez más, ¿por
qué tenemos este ⅔ y esta ponderación de ⅓? Porque
estamos dos veces más cerca de este punto que de
este punto. Ahora, si quisiéramos simplificarlo,
¿qué obtendríamos? Pues este 2 se cancelaría con
este otro 2 y esto es 0, entonces obtendríamos a +
b / 3 para la coordenada X y para la coordenada Y,
esto es 0, este 2 se cancela con este 2 y
obtenemos c / 3. Así que acabamos de encontrar
un punto que efectivamente se encuentra en esta
mediana azul. Ahora hagamos un ejercicio similar
con esta mediana de color rosa. Para la mediana
de color rosa ¿cuál es la coordenada del punto
sobre esta recta que está dos veces más lejos
del vértice que del lado opuesto? Bueno, sería
exactamente el mismo ejercicio: ponderamos al
doble estas coordenadas, por lo que la coordenada
X sería ⅔ • b / 2 + ⅓ • a, y luego la coordenada
Y sería ⅔ • c / 2 + ⅓ • 0, y ¿qué resulta? Bien,
veamos: este 2 se cancela con el otro 2 y nos
quedamos con b / 3 + a / 3, que es lo mismo que
a + b / 3, y por acá esto es 0, estos se cancelan
y nos queda c / 3. Noten que la misma coordenada
se encuentra tanto en la mediana azul como en la
mediana rosa, por lo que ese debe ser el punto
donde se intersecan. Veamos si esto también se
cumple para la mediana anaranjada. Para la mediana
anaranjada haremos exactamente lo mismo. Te
invito a que pauses el video y trates de calcular
por tu cuenta el valor de este punto. ¿Cuál es la
coordenada de este punto sobre la recta anaranjada
en donde esta distancia mide el doble de largo
que esta distancia? Hacemos lo mismo, ponderamos
al doble estas coordenadas de aquí, por lo que la
coordenada X de este punto va a ser ⅔ • a / 2 + ⅓
• b, y la coordenada Y va a ser ⅔ • 0 + ⅓ • c. ¿A
qué es igual esto? Esto se cancela con esto, a /
3 + b / 3 que es lo mismo que a + b / 3, y de este
lado esto es igual a 0 y nos queda c / 3. Noten
que acabamos de demostrar que exactamente la misma
coordenada se encuentra en las tres medianas,
por lo tanto las tres medianas se van a intersecar
en ese punto porque este punto existe en las tres
rectas. Es lo que acabamos de demostrar, y esto se
cumple para este triángulo arbitrario, y podemos
hacer que este triángulo tenga cualquier dimensión
que se nos ocurra con sólo asignar valores para a,
para b y para c. Y si vemos un triángulo que tiene
las mismas dimensiones, pero está trasladado o
tiene una orientación diferente, podemos hacer
transformaciones rígidas, las cuales no cambian
algunas de las dimensiones, y podemos demostrar
que esto también se cumplirá para ese triángulo.